excuse me I think we're ready to order
well I'm sorry that's not how things
work in this establishment someone will
come to you yes we're sorry no no
problem what was that
what well where was black Jeff black
Jeff what yeah black Jeff I read
somewhere that when you date a biracial
guy you're supposed to get the best of
both worlds so there are white Jeff
situations and there are black-jeff
situations and that was definitely a
black-jeff situation oh okay hi folks
I'm so sorry for the wait can I get you
bottled or tap water for the table this
evening how about I bottle your ass and
kick it down the stairs man we've been
waiting half an hour for one of you
mother is to show up I'm so I'm so sorry
I'll get you a bottle of our finest
premium water on the house that's what I
say a [ __ ] what are you doing black
Jeff that was black Jeff but he was just
trying to help us oh so white white Jeff
yes good evening I'm sorry to bother you
- I am the maitre d here at Chez Henri
oh yes what is it I am so sorry to
disturb you both but our establishment
has a certain dress code and Madame's um
decolletage is inappropriate
oh my god we're we're very sorry we
didn't know there was a dress code we'll
certainly remember for the next time but
they won't be no next time for you
looking at my woman and hug her day cold
chuckle chuckle ice or whatever you say
it made her brown here okay see it was
really a simple misunderstanding it all
started right there who is disrespecting
myself and my girl but we really love
this guy and he gave us exceptional a
sir we're gonna have to ask you to leave
you have to ask me Lito you have to ask
the black man to leave huh actually I
don't have to ask us to leaders want to
see ourselves out and we ain't never
coming back again though we really
appreciate your help that's oh no siento
mucho
watch your ass man let us reimburse you
for that break it's okay right after I
burn this hole
places a mother around everybody inside
of it by which I mean you're going to
get a very negative review on Yelp
you